okay let's talk about technocracy as
well as Freudian slips a couple
interesting discussions from the David
Pakman show subreddit which you can find
at david pakman.com slash our IDI di t
more than 7,000 david pakman show
viewers and listeners now participating
I mention it to you because we want to
foment robust community and conversation
on that subreddit no trolling though we
have moderators trolling not allowed
there was a post about technocracy
saying david what's your opinion on
technocracy title says it all here's
hoping he's gonna read it well I did
read it and this is something I'm
interested in so first let's start with
what is technocracy when we talk about
technocracy we talk about a government
or control of society or control of
industry by a sort of elite of technical
experts who basically see governance as
an engineering problem so there are some
obvious pros to a technocracy number one
we put people in power who know things
instead of people who are professional
politicians or mostly lawyers which is
what we have in American politics today
at least at the national level so if you
have people who know things you would
think that that would be a positive
change in government government when you
have people who are actually subject
matter experts the problems with
technocracy are number one who decides
who the experts are because if I said
let's put in experts on climate science
to actually work in government the right
will line up a long list of people they
say are climate science and climate
change experts would we agree that these
are the experts on climate science and
climate change no we would not so that's
one problem with technocracy who decides
who the experts are number two experts
in which fields right how do we decide
which fields are the important ones for
governing and then there's an important
question that's sort of like a
chicken-egg question or a causation
correlation question are lots of
politicians lawyers because you need law
knowledge to be a politician
or are lots of politicians lawyers
because being a lawyer makes you better
suited maybe because of how you've been
taught to think for example to be a
politician along the same lines we might
have Tech's expert tech experts and
scientists elected as politicians
elected officials not because they need
that technology to do the job of being a
politician but because their background
in science their background in tech
maybe the argument would go makes them
better suited for the types of thinking
that elected officials should be doing
the answer probably is like most things
a gray area you don't want a total
technocracy you want a balance right now
we have way too few people from tech and
from science in government and
particularly at the federal level but at
the same time you don't want to go
completely overboard and get people from
other disciplines out of government what
we we can say with certitude is just
having lawyers run government is not
something that has served us
particularly well over the last many
many decades also from the David Pakman
show subreddit somebody pointed out that
I had a Freudian slip when I did the
show on was it Monday or Tuesday Tuesday
where I was talking about Donald Trump's
Supreme Court pick and I said the
following and pat pat noticed it as well
we have had yet another major
development in the confirmation of
Donald Trump's Supreme Court prick pick
Brett Kavanaugh Supreme Court prick I
actually didn't even notice it when I
said it even though I corrected myself
that's interesting it went totally over
my head and it reminded me I think I I
don't remember all of the Freudian slips
that I've had on the David Pakman show
but one of my absolute favorites is this
one from over a year ago which I'll play
for you today Republicans Mike Lee and
Rand Paul voted against approving those
sanctions even Ted Cruz and [ __ ] Mitch
McConnell Freudian slip guys Mitch
McConnell excuse me uh Wow
we have to just continue right I mean
let's keep going uh we'll edit that out
don't worry about it maybe the most
important element of this well we didn't
edit it out and I think that that
probably is the
notorious Freudian slip on the show
right what was going on with that hair
to seem so different yeah I know it's
weird like I'm not aware of having
changed my hair for 10 years and I look
back a year and I'm like what on earth
was going on at the time it's very odd
anyway thanks to everybody who's
participating daily in the David Pakman
show subreddit join the conversation
david pakman.com slash our EDD IT